um
that's so nuanced the question i mean
should it exist
i thought i think i think it is there to
kind of give people that sense of you
have a responsibility when things fall
apart
but i i don't know i don't i don't know
if it should exist or not because
you know you didn't get paid to have the
kid in the first place
i mean i think if you're if
it's a tricky one i think if you if
you're good and you're a good person and
you want to look after your child you
will look after your child i don't think
for me i think state involvement is with
children is a bit of a no-no yeah it's
not what the guys should do it's like
should the government force men to pay
i don't like the word force i mean i
mean because you don't if you don't pay
child support you go to jail yeah so you
are forced it's like you don't in the uk
you don't go to jail
in uk but in america um
i think i think it depends does does the
opposite work in reverse in the united
states that's what you're referencing so
if you have a man who's got custody of
his child he's the woman obligated to
pay child support in america
um is she up it's not as common um it
does happen but they're usually
headlines because it's the exception
rather than the rule
i don't i don't believe in child support
at all i think you should get a job
like
in a failing economy it might be hard to
get if i miss the context i thought
child support was forcing the man to
give money to them yeah yeah no it is
and sometimes it's occasionally it's
reverse but i'm saying even in that
context i don't understand why you can't
get a job
as a girl
like because you're a woman i think even
when you've got a job you still have to
pay that i think i know in the uk it
works with residency so if you if you
know if a child lives five days out of
seven with yeah she gets the the benefit
and it's not just child support it will
be
state child benefit it will be universal
credit it will be anything else right
but i think it should just be
automatically 50 50. like if both
parents like not nothing no dv nothing
of that it should just be 50 50 and no
child support so i've got a because it's
an anecdotal story okay go ahead um
so when i was raising my son right and
and i
i mean his mother broke up
i was paying
uh her without the government right
involvement so we agreed on a fee every
month and i was paying that every month
and then i had my son half the week and
she had him
half the week so i was all right that's
cool for me and um
what happened was is that somebody said
to me
are you are you giving her money every
month and i was like yeah of course from
my son and they were like you're not
entitled to do that you have your son
half the week
and i was at
really
and so i went on the
gov website
and it stated yeah if two people are
cold
actually co-parenting
no one owes each other money yeah and i
was like oh what am i paying this money
for so when i informed her you know what
no more money
that's when problems began
and that was very interesting i'd like
to hear from the girls what you guys
think about child support
um i feel like it should is
if if you if the father is not
contributing
and he's not doing it just by you know
because he's supposed to and looking
after his child etc
and
they there is some relationships where
they they can't communicate they can't
come to a common
um ground the child lives with the
mother um all the time i do believe
there have to be something in place um
because again even if the mother is
working again sometimes
due to child care they have they can't
work certain hours they can't do certain
things and i feel like to give that
child a a a
decent life
you would as a father would want to
you know pay and do what you need to do
whether that's paying for after school
clubs i do think there's other ways of
contributing i don't but i do think cs
child support is very toxic as well at
the same time it can cause problems
but it there needs to be there also it
needs to be something in place for when
relationships or when parents can't come
to
an agreement why
because then the child gets
the child gets left left in a why should
the child suffer basically
you know do you think that incentivizes
women to make poor reproductive choices
because they get bailed out
so even if you pick the the guy that
clearly wasn't a good father
like you still get bailed out because we
should be picking men that
are will stay in the kids lives like you
seem to have a really good relationship
with you yeah i think that but there is
some times where you could go you've
heard stories sometimes people have been
with people they've they've been good
guy break up and they've they just
changed you know and you just but do we
base rules based on the exception i
think most girls that that happens to
they saw the red flags early on and they
just don't listen to anybody yeah like
yeah why are you laughing because it's
true it's true right yeah but i feel
like that it can change
i do feel like the csa at the moment is
been it is being used for the wrong
reasons and i also do think
that um it will be better if parents
could come to an you know an agreement i
do believe i don't think money is
everything because well i think that
sometimes hands-on help is more is more
better off to be honest but everyone's
different
okay what do you think
um i don't think the government should
be involved i think if uh two people are
mature enough to have a child they
should also be mature enough to both
provide for the child in whatever means
necessary um but like you said i do
think it's
necessary to have something in place for
if one party can't keep up their end of
the deal in looking after the child so i
think it should be harder to
okay what do you think um well i had a
similar um
story to you sarah one of my friends
close friends was in a situation it was
quite fairly recent actually in lockdown
where he couldn't provide um for his
children because he lost his job
and he was paying monthly a good rate
that was discussed before this encounter
and out of malice his ex was like okay
well i'm going to take it to you know
i'm going to take it to court and
get my um child maintenance increased
and that was very detrimental to his
mental health because this was out of
his control no one knew that the
pandemic was going to occur you know and
when you're doing such
you know when you're providing such duty
for your kids willingly you know despite
all of the the fights and the arguments
and the
breakouts that have occurred you're
still there for your child still trying
to um
provide for them and then
something happens and you can't no more
and then they they use the opportunity
because they've got like um the
government backing them up to now
account for um the
the finances just like do you think that
girls would make better reproductive
choices if they knew there were
consequences yes like if maybe they knew
child support wasn't an option if they
got pregnant
yeah i feel that there would be a lot of
premeditated decisions if i knew that um
you know if i'm gonna go out with a man
and he's he's not gonna be there for me
i'll make sure i'm gonna have my job and
make sure i have my house i'm gonna make
sure i'm i'm well equipped before i get
into that make sure you're on birth
control yeah as well
as well she wasn't gonna mention that
i didn't think i needed to i mean i i
hold myself to a high regard so yeah
wait before you carry on we've got to
start over here um if i let my brother
just read that
hold up this is for you charlie the rise
in single five